then rain you ready to party I decided
to step out of my comfort zone a little
bit and let the boys plan Henry's first
big day out hi I'm Hannah I'm the world
suitcase mom and for the past month we
have not left the house this is because
I have Oh sneezes and I had postpartum
anxiety and it's hard for me to leave
but we're gonna let my older brothers
plan my big day out so hopefully it's
not too crazy okay wish me luck I should
start off by explaining how postpartum
anxiety kind of manifests for me it's
different than postpartum depression
both are very serious and both should be
discussed with a doctor because it is
more common than you think
so for me postpartum anxiety it's a lot
of intrusive thoughts most of it is like
germophobia it can snowball into
something really crippling where I
become afraid of interacting with people
because they're just walking germs to me
it's not logical
and so I'm actually in therapy for it
I'm not ashamed to say that I am seeking
help I really need it what I've quickly
realized this time around is my
postpartum anxiety is not only affecting
me it actually affects my entire family
my older boys want to go do stuff on the
weekends they want to take Henry places
they want to get out of the house while
the boys understand I can also tell that
they're disappointed that I'm not
participating in family stuff so I
decided to step out of my comfort zone a
little bit and let the boys plan Henry's
first big day out it's hard to plan a
day for a one-month-old because they
don't really do much so the points
pretty much picked activities that they
wanted to do and decided that they would
show Henry how to enjoy these activities
the plan was pretty pretty standard for
my kids start the morning off with
Starbucks move on to mini-golf then the
park then pizza and frozen yogurt it's
all the things that my kids love in one
day
Henry pretty much he's got the same
cycle eat sleep poop eat sleep poop cry
cry cry eat sleep poop okay today is the
day of the big outing and I'm gonna be
honest we had pretty much the worst
night sleep wives of all time last night
I'm quiet cuz I'm trying to get into the
nap one night of bad sleep can
completely derail an entire weekend one
noisy man can completely derail an
entire
getting shoes on more you ready to go
Henry
[Applause]
we are on our way to our very first stop
which is what so luxe Henry what will
you have
tall milk steamed milk noodle now again
we are not sponsored by Starbucks I love
Starbucks I used to work there I wish
they would sponsor me
hashtag Starbucks sponsor Hana I woke up
these smell the food and you woke up
Henry can you smell the food it was
almost like Henry's rite of passage like
once you've gone to Starbucks with our
family you're in you're in for life our
next job is mini-golf which I don't
really know how well you're gonna play
Henry but the boys really wanted to go
it's very important that he do this on
his first day out they said so mini-golf
it is it had been a hot minute since
I've been mini golfing I have never been
very good at it but the boys love to go
they've gone with Matt several times and
so they were really excited to show me
how skilled they are at all of it why in
particular is very intense about it
he I think could be a very good golfer
at some point because he is so intense
[Music]
it's so funny to see tiny humans doing
like grown-up human stuff please let me
know if you've experienced this but
whenever my kid is seated in the car
seat and poops the poop ends up not in
the diaper at all and just immediately
goes all up the back so straight away at
the mini-golf place we had a blowout in
true 3rd kid fashion I just changed him
right in his stroller I don't care like
you got to do what you got to do when
you're out with your baby and you have
your older kids I'm not gonna take him
back to the car and like lay out a bunch
of stuff to change him now Matt had a
very special job this day he was my
official sanitizer
so I don't with the mini-golf very well
but I know myself and so we came armed
with lots of hand sanitizer wipes and
all of that and so before anybody
touched anything Matt had to fully
sanitize every piece of everything in
order to keep me comfortable which
that's marriage baby turned out
mini-golf is actually the perfect
activity for me with my postpartum
anxiety because I could control pretty
much the whole situation I could
sanitize all the parts included it's
outdoors so fresh air and people are
taking turns at each hole so it's not
super crowded you're not in close
contact with other people however before
we left the boys wanted to go to another
part of this park
that completely sent me over the edge
now don't get me wrong this arcade was
very nice I'm sure it was very clean
this whole place was really amazing it's
just me literally every button on every
Sheen looked like 45 different people's
germy hands coated all over everything
I just we're gonna wait outside while
they do that yeah okay we made a pit
stop to change because it's getting cold
um I mean cold for LA but it's a little
chilly we weren't dressed warming up and
now we're headed to the park you guys
ready for the park oh yeah you know what
a park is yes I do
poor Henry can't talk so we have to talk
for him and everyone pretty much has
their own Henry voice Henry are you
excited nobody said go to the park and
play with Jackson
oh yeah Jackson Henry said I think the
appeal of a park with little kids I mean
my kids always want to go to the park
and it's it's the open space they can
run as fast as they want there's so much
room there's so much stuff to do like
climbing and sliding and tumbling and
all that stuff yeah totally
watching you guys oh yes he's fascinated
at the park Henry got very hungry
there's a lot of debate around nursing
in public and how you should nurse when
your baby is hungry and you're out in a
public space so what I ended up doing
was kind of hiding in the corner behind
some trees and I nursed Henry under my
sweater I tried to be discreet but like
it's a part of life this body part
exists to feed humans it doesn't exist
for people to obsess over it so if you
can't differentiate then maybe you
should cover your own face
breastfeeding not sexual alright that
was some good playtime
um did not take Henry out of the
stroller because there were so many kids
on the playground and I am terrified of
germs and I literally heard like 45
sneezes and the time we were there so he
stayed in the stroller
but the boys taught him everything he
needs to know about playing and that's
all that matters so the Sun is starting
to set and it's getting chilly outside
so we have a plan B for pizza and frozen
yogurt we've been calling it the three
P's or the three P's left of the day
park Pizza pose and yogurt but now it's
gonna be four p's Park pizza party pie
scream and we're gonna have to do it at
home because it's getting chilly Henry
are you ready to party we just walked
into the house we're gonna do collective
bath time I'm gonna order the pizza got
a bunch of ice cream sundae stuff the
minute I walked in the door to my house
I just felt overwhelmingly better it's
always good to try new things and I
think it was important for me to test my
boundaries but at a certain point you
know it becomes detrimental and a little
too much for me to handle and so I was
really glad that we decided to take the
pizza party and ice cream party back to
our house so the boys wanted to show him
how to eat pizza and let him smell it so
we'll see if he wakes up and he'll come
party with us the boys got their pizza
we developed a method for Henry to try
it which is through wafting the scent
over to him so we wafted some pizza
smell over to Henry everyone just had a
great time we got our ice cream sundaes
I have dried strawberries chocolate
sauce and
schmooze for toppings three kinds of ice
cream and for Henry some milk coming up
and I let the kids serve themselves
because I was holding Henry and so they
took full advantage and scooped like
5000 scoops into their bowls but that's
okay it was their day well don't mind if
I do
adding a baby to the family really
changes the dynamic and in those early
stages my time is super monopolized I am
with the baby pretty much all the time
because I am his food source and he
needs constant care and so it's really
important to involve the older kids in a
way that it's fun for them and they feel
like they're really a part of things
why how did Henry do so so good whose
team was he on me and so they don't feel
like the baby's replacing them in any
way they don't feel jealous about the
baby taking up more of my time so my
anxiety leading up to the day was really
high just because I was nervous about
leaving the house having that day out
didn't cure my anxiety or anything but
it was definitely a big step in figuring
out something that I can do that I'm
comfortable with and will help me you
know how to Lee cope with the anxiety if
you feel like you might have symptoms of
postpartum anxiety or postpartum
depression definitely check out this
link below and talk to somebody about it
what did you guys think of today is
amazing he's mad oh yeah but of course
the day wasn't over until Henry once
again made his mark he's pooping a lot I
can't tell if it's poop or fart hey did
you hear that okay there's no way this
doesn't leave me at the back right now
oh yeah oh my god it's all over my hand
so that's all I got for today I'm Hannah
and what did you think of Henry's day
out what would you have done with him
instead let me know on Instagram and if
you please excuse me I am nursing til
next time
[Music]